one project we hear you will not return
to a season 18 of grey's does your
stance remain the same will you not
return
and going into season 18 it's almost
it's nearing
the amount of time that i've been the
same time that i've been off of the show
so it really speaks so highly to the how
the show really
uh has really found a place in people's
hearts
uh and that i'm so happy to have been a
part of that
and as a as an artist i you know all i
can offer is to is to come along to the
things that i'm doing now and
and hopefully people will like it you're
elegant even saying i'm not gonna go
back
my daughter is 14 and everything about
me
is repellent to her except
that sandra is in my show because she's
a psychotic grey's anatomy fan
and so it's the thing that i'm like
leaning on
in a way that is so weird it's a little
bit like a
guy who's a little porsche he's like
an inferiority who like drives around in
the porsche like being like
that's how i am about sandra to my
daughter
tell me what to do you're going to
apologize i'm so sorry i oh my god not
to me dumbass
i am the chair of the department let's
shake this place up
sandra knocked it out of the park girl
you are electrifying in this
card it's just there's so many layers to
this
and you know again heart humor you guys
are tackling topics like
aging diversity uh different cultures
head-on with that heart and humor
how special did that feel for you sandra
to be able to participate
in a series like this it's just
uh there's a quote from babette's feast
which is something like throughout the
world
there is one long cry from the heart of
the artist
which is give me the chance to do my
very best
and i absolutely feel like amanda gave
me that chance and it's to be able to
play something as complex
and also in an arena that i am
interested in
uh exploring uh the ethnicity and the
culture of the character because
honestly as as an actor of color you
know i mean
it's we're slow on that we're slow on
that part of the of of the storytelling
that what makes us full characters is
that you're going fully into
not staying there it's not a pointed
thing but it's a living breathing part
of our life
as women of color we're not stomping
around
announcing it it just is a part of our
life
so when it is a part of your life the
way that you talk to another woman of
color
is different than the way that you talk
to your dad who might speak another
language
you know it's all different so just to
be able to
to to be able to honestly fire
on all levels was was a
was a great privilege amanda i mean
what an exceptional job here what
exactly
sparked the concept for this project for
the series
i'm gonna embarrass her but um sandra
was my muse
yeah i really love the idea of setting
something in an english department
and i love the idea of a newly promoted
chairperson whose colleague progresses
in the classroom
and i couldn't stop thinking about
how it would feel if you
not only were maybe slightly in love
with this person but also if you
truly believed in your heart that this
person was heretofore
a person full of decency um
and yet you're supposed to be the
harbinger change and changing culture
and i was really excited about putting
them in this sort of terrible position
yeah i mean there's so many different
positions
so many different elements and facets of
the story it's just it's fascinating
it's got heart it's got humor
how did you snag miss sandra
and of course just produce to star
and then the men behind game of thrones
maybe aka your hubby
um well the funny thing about david and
dan is
we kind of work together anyway so um
this was
the first time we did it in an official
capacity um but
with sandra i really just had my heart
set on her
and i couldn't really think of anybody
else that i wanted for this part and i
felt like it's really hard to find
you know like all actresses think we all
think we're like um
we read as like super intelligent but i
really couldn't think of someone who
could come off as professorial
you